well that just you know it's the reason
that people should read the book we're
still here because there are Indians all
around us all among us but they don't
wear their traditional regalia and their
feathers to work or out to the grocery
store you know so they are still here mi
t--'s John Pearman describes the
disintegration of American culture and
the opinion of Americans abroad in his
book 100 ways America is screwing up the
world he spoke about it recently at
politics and prose bookstore in
Washington DC for about an hour
have you ever watched the news and
thought about the state of the world and
asked yourself how many ways is America
screwed enough the world 5 10 maybe 20
well according to tonight's author John
Chairman executive director of MIT
Center for International Studies there
are a hundred ways or more perhaps that
America is screwing up the world thanks
from the list here a few that caught my
eye altering the Earth's climate
that's way number one consumerism that's
way number 45 Las Vegas way 85 nuclear
weapons way 18 the attack on science way
46 and my favorite Mel Gibson he is way
64
to tell us more about how America is
screwing up the world please help me
welcome John chairman thank you very
much Mel Gibson I got lucky with Mel I
handed in the manuscript in January and
then although it wasn't about him being
drunk and disorderly anti-semitic yes
we'll get to that later very nice to be
here back in Washington I lived in
Washington for ten years which is why I
have a chapter on Washington I don't
know if any of you have seen it I want
to apologize for it in advance if any of
you actually like living here but I like
living here so it's nice to be back and
I see a lot of friends here and family
and people who were living in the same
building and on a board and so on and so
forth it's it's like a homecoming so
thank you for coming I'm going to speak
about a couple of themes in the book
which I wrote at the behest of the
publisher an unusual circumstance for
policy wonks and academics who can
barely get the ear of a publisher most
of the time but this particular
publisher HarperCollins called me one
day and asked me if I wanted to write
this book or would I'd like to discuss
it and I thought it was a provocative
title mm-hmm so these attention-getting
but it did give me an opportunity and I
was keen to do it because of this
opportunity to to discuss or to to
really start an argument an argument
about the u.s. role in the world
something that we tend to bring up in
our public discourse only when something
really goes wrong like Iraq for example
we'll come back to that too
but rarely do we examine with much care
or in my case some amusement and some
irony the the way that America is seen
in the world and what kinds of impacts
we actually have this is a big bold
dynamic country largest economy in the
world popular culture that is just
consumed avidly everywhere in the world
and yet I think most Americans are not
really aware of how much these things
affect other people and so that's the
place I started from but I found myself
as I as I built the hundred ways built
the list and wrote the chapters I found
myself sort of alternating between about
four different categories a one was the
environmental destruction I concentrated
a lot on this it's the it's the number
one way altering the earth which is
about climate change because these kinds
of activities toxic waste dumping
pesticides etc etc are are ways that
that have been unfolding for many years
they're not really
they are partisan issues but they've
happened under both Democrats and
Republicans without adequate remedy and
there are things that are going to
affect us affect Americans and the rest
of the world for many many years to come
so that was that was the first category
the second one was economics and
economics is hard to write in a popular
way so I didn't do a lot with that but I
did write a bit of bad things like our
policies in the third world that in
which we demand the government's
Institute privatization and
marketization as it's called which has
had I think in many places catastrophic
results the third category would be
politics
or politics by other means as we can say
it politely which is of course war
interventions dictators support their of
problems with upholding standards of
human rights and so on quite a few of
those I specialized at MIT and have for
some years and global security issues
and I really had to restrain myself from
writing more about these kinds of topics
but I did so by by taking up themes in
the in the fourth category which is
culture and I had a lot of fun with
those things like Hollywood violence
that's actually the Mel Gibson chapter
consumerism television
Paris Hilton another enduring icon of
America the self-help movement the New
Age movement things like that the Paris
Hilton chapter is kind of an interesting
one because it illustrates how how
something that really began is kind of a
meant to be just sort of amusing and to
say you know rather obvious things about
about pop culture that you know here's
this this icon of American pop culture
who as everyone has said countless times
is famous for being famous and you know
as a celebrity without talent and so on
all of which may be true but as I as I
got into it I realized that there's
there's actually serious diseases that
are associated with celebrity worship a
pair of social diseases what it's called
and this is particularly problematic for
young women and girls teenage girls who
begin to identify so strongly with a
celebrity or more
they believe that they know the
celebrity and they stop forming actual
relationships with other people serious
issue and that happened to me a lot
while I was writing this book and it was
particularly fun to do with these
cultural topics which I don't claim to
be expert on but but have often amusing
sort of beginnings in these chapters but
but then lead to more serious points and
of course the larger point being that
America is is not only doing this to
itself in some important ways but is
spreading these things out into the rest
of the world I would include in the
cultural thing although it it sort of
moves over into into politics as well
the the evangelical movements for
example in this in this case it's not
just incidental that it's spreading
around the world it's an intentional
policy of finding as one evangelical
website says finding the lost souls of
the world and converting them to
Christianity and they described India as
a lost continent of of a billion a
billion lost souls which I thought is
the most astonishing kind of conjecture
or assertion of an imperial vision that
you could that you could look at an
ancient religion like this as as
representing lost souls that need to be
converted now of course not all cultural
things not all political things not even
economic policy is intentionally being
spread around the world like this a lot
of it is is unintentional and this is
where we get into the three what I would
say three sort of themes that are
threads of ideas that that work their
way through the book as I said at the
outset the America
are largely oblivious to the to the to
the depth and the breadth of this effect
of the effect of any and all of these
things and therefore bad guys can get
away with bad policies all the time I
have a friend who here in Washington who
used to work on the hill and I think he
used to call there's certain legislation
that they would call something like 3:00
a.m. legislation so I can't remember
exactly what the phrase was but by that
he meant you know things that happen in
the middle of the night when nobody's
paying attention basically now that's
that way all the time you know because
we're so distracted by the war on terror
such as it is something we can discuss
in the Q&A on the war in Iraq the and
and these kind of you know Hollywood
distractions of various cons that it's
very hard to focus in the public
discourse and and and consciousness on
on things that matter a second theme is
that many of the trends we see in
politics and culture extol individualism
at the expense of public action and
public goods as I look through the list
and and and of course reread countless
times my own writing I realized that I
kept coming back to a couple of themes
one of which was how you know the self
you concede in some of the trivial
things like self-help movement in and
and the in the New Age and and things of
that kind
television and you can see it in larger
policy issues the ideology of
marketization for example the way that
we create trade relations the American
dream I have a chapter on that
this is all about individual effort
individual getting ahead material
acquisitiveness to some extent this is
the ideology that has I think undercut
the the long-standing notion of
solidarity of community of solving
problems together of of taking public
discourse in public action
seriously the sort of the highest good
of society and of governance and both of
these things
the obliviousness the individualism lead
to what I would call unsustainable
behavior that is it's not just
unsustainable in you know Bush's
recklessness in in the Middle East it
also has to do with this the the our
incapacity there are the incapacity of
the earth to sustain the kind of
lifestyles that Americans even
middle-class Americans I don't mean just
wealthy Americans although I do have a
chapter on the filthy rich that I think
you'll enjoy that middle-class Americans
have have adopted you know everything
from SUVs to - you know McMansions to
commuting great distances to other
things many of which of course have to
do with oil dependency but it's it's
it's it's bigger than that
it's a much deeper problem of both
obliviousness to the rest of the world
and its needs and a kind of
individualism that says why should I
care why why should I sell my SUV when I
get so much enjoyment out of it well the
reason is because SUVs are bad for the
rest of the earth and other reasons as
well but but it's but there's no I think
there's much less of a kind of a social
consciousness about these things in
agreement that the that that personal
responsibility is important to the
future of this country and to the right
of the world so finally then back to the
question why why a hundred ways in the
end I think that the the role of of
criticism in our culture is also
something that has declined at least
toleration for criticism has declined
along with the rise of the right wing in
this country I was on I've been doing a
lot of radio shows as one has want to do
in this book writing business and I was
on Michael Medved show the other day now
this is an experience in itself but I
don't know how many of you know Michael
who Michael Medved is but he's made his
bones as a film critic and now is
basically another right wing talk show
host and the the vitriolic denunciation
of me by his listeners and by him in
different ways for having the temerity
to write a book with this title none of
them had read the book of course was it
was really palpable I mean it was
expected it so I wasn't I wasn't shocked
or upset by it but but it was quite
remarkable how you get the same kind of
you know phrases like why don't you go
live in China used to be in Russia and
now it's China I don't know what that
says about they didn't say Cuba but but
but I mean one thing after another you
know you're living in an ivory tower oh
you're in Cambridge of course that's the
way you feel and so on I felt like
answering him in French but
my French isn't good enough so I
couldn't do it but anyway what what my
point here is that is that even the
simple role of criticism and a lot of
the book is meant to be just
tongue-in-cheek and and and a lot of it
is is actually criticizing liberals and
and sort of liberal shibboleths it's not
all going in one direction I have a
chapter on their Clintons for example
which has already gotten me into some
trouble and and other things
gangster-rap Paris Hilton etc but what I
try to explain when I'm given a chance
is that I think that this is sort of
like tough love for America right I mean
this is this is what everybody loves
this idea of tough love you know the
principle in Harlem the principle in
south east who gives us students tough
love and this changes their lives well
you know this is what I'm trying to do
tough love for all of America you see my
heart is big enough for all of America
which worries my doctors but but
ultimately I think that this is really
this kind of book not the book
specifically but the spirit of criticism
the spirit of taking your country
seriously the issue seriously and
looking at them with your eyes wide open
is ultimately an act of citizenship of
good citizenship and we should all be
good citizens right I mean we should all
be informed we should all be active we
should all be alert to things that we're
doing wrong as a country or a community
a city what-have-you and we should be
empowered to say so empowered in the
sense of being able to to engage in this
debate to start an argument as I said at
the at the beginning without being
dismissed as being an agent of who's
left Fidel Castro me
and ultimately what I I suggest at the
end of the book I have a chapter about
the 10 things America does right and in
some ways this chapter was simply meant
to assure the readers that I was capable
of complimenting the United States but I
had a had another purpose in this and
that was to was to say there are things
that America does right I mean we all
know that and there's a lot of
cheerleading for that kind of thing but
I want to set a marker for what I think
these things are and to say and and
there are things like fairness and and
you know educational excellence and and
immigration and and other things not all
of which are perfectly embodied in our
politics but I think the in the long in
the long view they are but but the
baseline here and I'll finish with this
is that the we should be able to
articulate what we think these
principles are as a country and if we
don't live up to them then we should say
that we don't live up to them and that's
what this book is really about it's
about principles of action of fairness
of equity in the world of sustainable
you know trying to create a sustainable
environment and lifestyle about about
diplomacy over military action as a
leading edge of foreign policy of
quality and common sense in in pop
culture and so on and if we do those
things if we are just sensible and and
loyal to our own principles I think that
writing a book like this in the future
would be much more difficult to do thank
you
so we'll take some questions and
comments yeah come to the microphone
please yes I wanted to ask you a few
questions about one topic are you
familiar with Noam Chomsky okay my
colleague ok so I wanted to catch spirit
or yeah I wanted to ask you how what's
his how do the students and the faculty
at MIT view him he is a professor of
linguistics and also a professor of
philosophy so what's his a concern in
philosophy I mean what did he he study
in particular in philosophy because he
does act as as a kind of political
philosopher it seems to me which is a
very interesting topic and I was
wondering you know what your view is as
well of Noam Chomsky if you could just
elaborate on on him a little well I
can't speak for what his philosophy is
you know he he made his reputation as as
a linguist and a revolution in
linguistics I should say and in that
sense he is he is much honored and I
think in in the academic world and at
MIT he doesn't teach any longer at MIT
as some PhD students but so his his
presence around campus is probably less
than it was some years ago I think the
Chomsky I was actually reading about a
year or so ago I was reading some of his
his work around Vietnam because I was
interested in the group of dissidents
including Howard Zinn was wrote the
foreword to my book
this group of this dissidents and how
how was that they were framing the
debate over Vietnam
early in the conflict 64 65 66 before it
became unpopular and Chomsky's writings
were really they're quite interesting
you should go back and look at them I
think there's some collected there's a
you know a portable Chomsky or something
like that there's a couple of
collections of his of his work that are
that are current in print and he had a
capacity for doing what I was talking
about earlier which was to juxtapose
America's ideals against its actions
particularly of course in Southeast Asia
and he was very thorough in his in his
in his research in his and his
exposition and and and this of course
was I think influential certainly for
the large campus movement and the war at
that time since that time he's gotten
into some hot water about Israel and
Palestinians although I don't really
know that the details of that but on
some other issues like East Timor he was
he was one of the first people in this
country to point out the Indonesian
repression in East Timor he was
instrumental in getting international
action on that so for that reason alone
and his opposition to Vietnam not to
mention his academic work I think he is
someone to be celebrated peculiar twist
of fate he and I are both have books
being prosecuted by the Turkish
government right now I wrote a book ten
years ago called spoils of war which was
about the American relationship with
Turkey and their war against the Kurds
or the civil war in Turkey and how we
were supplying arms to them and so on
and it is it was translated into Turkish
and and soon after that the publisher
was brought up on charges of
insulting the state insulting the
military insulting editor can a long
list of things of course those are
things that I did but I'm not going back
to Turkey to stand trial so
unfortunately the publisher is in my
stead but Chomsky is in the same boat
and has been before with the same
publisher so we've been working a little
bit on together on on statements of
solidarity with with the publisher yes
looks like a fun book and it looks like
it's very balanced and I love the fact
you included the 10 things that America
does right I agree with all of them
I'm glad you included diversity in the
good things and multiculturalism as one
of the annoying things because I I find
that too and I think it's important to
make a distinction but in that way among
your 10 I also feel there's a real
inherent conflict in too and I think a
lot of good intention people are feeling
this conflict and I just wanted you to
clear it up a little bit it's between
the rule of law which I just think is
absolutely vital and I think one reason
a lot of people come to this country is
because they the appeal we have a strong
rule of law but obviously you don't
include immigration law is one of those
because you also say open doors and that
seems to me like you're taking more of a
libertarian view of immigration that
it's an open border sort of situation so
I just wanted you to clear that up
because I think a lot of people are very
conflicted about that we believe in
diversity we believe in our immigration
but when it comes to immigration law
we're having a real trouble saying you
know we have it and that means some
people can come in and some people can't
and we have a long we have to enforce it
so how do you deal with that well good
question
I hope not all the questions are going
to be this difficult to answer
on the rule of law what I really was
really talking about there was not so
much specific applications but but
generally that America is always prided
itself on you know nation of laws not
man and that sort of thing which you
know largely is true and of course there
are lots and lots of things that one
could point to including you know right
now the Bush administration's sort of
stretching things on a lot of in a lot
of areas having to do mainly with with
national security and say oh no no no no
this is not the role of law well I think
the the overall drift of the American
experience has been to uphold the rule
of law in in you know in a fairly
consistent fashion I mean you know
sometimes the laws haven't been very
good you know we went for many many
years in which segregation and other
kinds of racial discrimination was legal
essentially and sometimes the Supreme
Court would rule in such ways that would
make owners things legal so it's you
know it's a mixed record to be sure but
I think that it's a powerful symbol for
a world in which in which law is often
simply a an instrument of state power in
a way that has no independent life of
its own and and so on so I that was
basically what I was driving it there
the immigration issue is an interesting
one I I I got you know lucky with Mel
Gibson I got a little bit unlucky with
the immigration debate because that
flared up right after I finished this
book I think I would have taken it up a
little bit more earnestly had I written
the book later it is true that I'm not
for perfectly open board I mean totally
open borders I think there do need to be
laws and enforced laws about who comes
in who gets legal status and so on
the problem is and and always has been
with the so-called illegal immigration
problem
is that we have often as a country we've
often been trying to solve a problem
that initially didn't really exist in
other words going back to the 50s 60s
70s even into the 80s most Mexican
immigration we're talking mainly that
Mexican immigration Mexican workers
coming across the border would work as
seasonal agricultural workers and then
they would go back to Mexico and this
was viewed as actually a very good
solution to labor shortages in certain
sectors not just agriculture but a few
other things what happened was in in
starting in the 1980s that that laws
began to be passed that made it harder
for them to get across the border more
Border Patrol's fences in some places
around San Diego for example and and
these actions even though it did not
reduce the actual flow of immigrants
into this country of illegal immigrants
it raised the costs of coming into the
United States significantly for these
people and so the result of that was
that they tended to stay longer and then
began to bring their families because
they knew they were going to stay longer
so in other words a so-called solution
to this problem which was never really a
problem to begin with actually created a
much larger problem instead of having a
temporary workforce which satisfied just
about everybody's needs you now have
people coming in and staying for much
longer periods of time essentially
permanent or semi-permanent and illegal
and that has you know lots of issues for
their access to health care the cost of
health care particularly in in border
towns education and so on so I think
that we were foolish in the first place
to accede to a kind of a political
impulse to to tag immigrants as a
problem when in fact they were not I
won't say that there's no
problems associated with it because
there are problems for the border towns
they should get more federal aid there
should be there ways to deal with that
but to build a fence which is basically
what is being proposed now and much
greater border control is is a very
severe reaction probably one that won't
work and a bad symbol besides I think
it's telling I'll just I'll stop here I
think it's telling that this issue
flared up so dramatically in the midst
of the Iraq war and and and and the
sharp decline of US public support for
the Iraq war which is a historical
pattern about immigration that goes back
to the beginning of the 20th century
when the nation is under national stress
for one reason or another economic
stress national security stress
something else immigrants are often
tagged as being a problem and it's a
diversionary tactic by demagogic
politicians there is not an immigration
problem in this country not a big one I
know you disagree you're shaking your
head that's your right but I would argue
this right down to the last moment thank
you for your question though my question
is gonna be simple and probably
simplistic but I wanted to ask you about
I read a book called a while ago called
the confessions of an economic hitman a
very disturbing book for me anyway
it talks and awful lot about an America
that I knew was there but I guess didn't
want to admit that I know was there was
there in South Africa it's there in a
lot of places and I was thinking that if
we didn't have this type of policy and
didn't support this type of behavior
which has all kinds of economic benefits
for our country maybe we would have less
problems was the rest of the world
including immigration I'm aware of the
book I haven't read it I actually
someone sent it to me and I started to
read a little bit and I and I had the
problem I had with it was that there's
no way to verify what this guy is saying
basically I mean it's a real problem you
know I mean he could be right in which
case I mean he could be telling the
truth in which case it's really from
what I understand of the book a
horrifying thing but it's it's really
hard to know how to take this I know
it's getting a lot of play now I should
probably should probably read it but it
is you know it's about a lot of
clandestine ugly stuff that's been going
on at the behest of the US government
and corporations and so on but I'm not
quite sure I'm convinced but I think we
have to believe some of it anyway yeah
the problem is which much bits to
believe in which it's not I used to
travel to South Africa with my husband
and we were having we were not dealing
with apartheid or the South African
government he worked for a huge mining
company that did business all the time
with South Africa and did all kinds of
incredible things in Botswana and
Namibia starvation people were wiped out
all this gonna so I'm sure there's
there's a lot of nasty things that
happened there's no question yeah thank
you thank you to follow up on this
lady's comment or her I mean if you go
back and look at the history of America
there's a lot of stuff they're dealing
with Native Americans dealing with
Africans dealing with Mexicans and so
forth so it it's to the point where you
tend to almost believe those books
rather than deny them and almost
somebody has to come up and show you the
denial if you realize the history ok the
points are this one a lot of what's done
in the name of America is in American
corporations so I don't like the fact
that we always label things America when
a lot of it is our corporate behavior
the point that I'm gonna address to you
to ask you about is that the awareness
and your your book would probably raise
the awareness but the awareness is
actually lagging behind the events right
now in the world in other words world
events and things are happening so
rapidly getting embroiled in these wars
and so forth that the public is so far
behind in the realization of what's
going on what do you expect I mean your
effort to bring these things to the
surface is good but the fact of the
matter is the events now are surpassing
the awareness of the leadership - and
we're we're gonna suffer and the final
thing is it's not just America I mean
we're talking to some degree about human
nature I mean many of the empires have
done similar type things
ya know skewness is not a comparative
thing I mean I in fact I say somewhere
that it's not there are other people
there's just the constancy when you when
you have when you're head of other
people to take advantage of that so well
yeah yes and no I guess you know one
hopes that the global norms have changed
in such a way that it's less acceptable
to to treat people badly even if you're
powerful but I do point out that it's
you know this is not saying that America
is the worst country or anything like
that it's because the British and
Soviets and you know all kinds have lots
to answer for there's no question about
that but you know I'm an American we're
here I'm gonna write about America and
of course we are now the you know the
hyper power or whatever them current
phrases you know your your your question
about what can be done sort of thing is
what how do the events are outrunning
our ability to govern I think is a very
interesting point I mean I want to speak
to that rather than try to explain what
I think can be done
alternatively I do have I should say I
do have a website John Chairman calm in
which I have the main reason for making
the website was to have references for
the book because of course we just want
to have footnotes in this book that
would be just too academic looking so
and in those references I have links to
lots and lots of organizations that are
working on the problems that I'm
identify
so there is you know people do work on
these things and some work on them very
effectively and I'm sure there are many
people here tonight at work in some of
those organizations so it's it's not
hopeless but what your comment about
events sort of outrunning our ability to
control or govern there is a very good
example and we haven't talked about it
yet and that is of course Iraq and I
think it does need to be said because
the the reasons for going into Iraq and
pursuing it the way it's been pursued
really bring together all kinds of the
issues that I talk about in this book
and I do thread a lot about Iraq
throughout the book I mean petroleum
dependency we you know clearly would not
be in Iraq if it were not for its oil
reserves the sort of cultural
insensitivities the scene the entire
world as a as a nail and and we have a
hammer and that sort of thing and now in
Iraq we see that events have gotten out
of our capacity to control them to
govern them there literally is no good
solution now for Iraq maybe there never
was but at least the massive amount of
killing and mayhem that has occurred
since March of 2003 would not have taken
place had we not invaded and there may
have been other ways to deal in fact
there were other ways to deal with
Saddam Hussein as Thomas Rick's points
out in his excellent book called fiasco
that the you know the sanctions and we
the sanctions had their problems too but
sanctions that weakened him the Clinton
action in in 98 had weakened him and so
on he was a wounded wounded leader but
in any case my point here is that
through a certain amount of arrogance
through a certain kind of mindset about
our role in the world
we were led into this fiasco that is
going to have impacts in that region for
years and years and years to come one of
one of my chapters is about the Reagan
doctrine which surprisingly enough has
gotten very little treatment after the
fact either academic or more popular
writing yet here was here was an
innovation so to speak of Ronald Reagan
while he was president to unseat
Communists governments or you know
sympathetic to communism through
supporting guerrilla movements the you
know exhibit a was Afghanistan you know
what can you say about the results of
that of that initiative
well what came out of Afghanistan among
other things was the Taliban and al
Qaeda and a number of other things now
even now the poppy production is back to
record levels there the heroin suppliers
of the world and so on and so forth a
catastrophe for the people of that
region all done for you know a set of
ideological beliefs Cambodia another
example Angola a million people dead
Mozambique chameleon people did
Nicaragua now a you know beleaguered by
drug running and and poverty and so on I
mean one colossal disaster after another
and we're doing it again in Iraq and
part of it is we don't have historical
memory we don't have public debates
about these things it's their boat into
to criticize Reagan's why spend a lot of
time talking about Reagan the the idea
that the United States caused you know
al-qaeda or or you know drug running in
Central America or what-have-you
which of course is too simplistic but
nevertheless is something that we should
be able to discuss
especially when we're facing these as
major problems a drug problem terrorism
problem and so on so my point here a
little bit off your question but is to
say that yes events often get out of
control from what is seemingly intended
and what we need are better and better
you know citizens better and better ways
to engage on these issues and to hold
the government accountable and
corporations accountable to sets of
standards that that promote stability
and and peace and all the other things
that we all say were in favor of I was
fascinated how much Christianity I found
in your book I see you have the chapters
on the puritanical ethic and on Mel
Gibson on Christmas and then a most
Christian nation what would Jesus say
you seem to be very well-versed in the
Gospels and particularly the Sermon on
the Mount
hallelujah brother I mean so I was
curious about your I assume you have
some kind of Christian background or I
do and then I and then I was very
encouraged by you you do in the book
optimistically about the 10 things
America does right in the world you end
with human rights and that does seem to
be something that Christians use
agnostics atheists left and right they
they do seem to be in agreement with and
you know I don't see much of the rest of
the world standing up in the way that
Americans do well the human rights issue
is is complicated because we have been
in many ways the principal promoter
of human rights at least among major
nations for many many years but it's
been done very imperfectly and it's been
done imperfectly I think because other
other interests so-called security
interests usually where economic
interests tend to trump our concern for
human rights when it really comes down
to a specific place so for example you
can remember the the
[Music]
the period of the the 1970s when Jimmy
Carter was president he was the human
rights president right and one of the
places that human rights might have been
applied more rigorously and Senator
Kennedy and others did try to do this
through Senate resolutions was in Iran
and and Iran is a very good example of a
place where we turned a blind eye for
many many years in fact installed the
repressive regime in 1953 that repressed
human rights in this very large very
important Islamic country and not only
supported the Shah but helped him
suppress things like you know the left
and and others who might have given some
political pluralism and legitimacy to
the regime and of course it all
collapsed catastrophic ly with the with
the rise of the Islamic Revolution which
of course has turned into a rather
repressive mess and here we are at
loggerheads again that's an example of
where human rights were not promoted in
a steady consistent realistic way inside
Iran by the United States and and the
results have been a disaster and and
that has been true in a lot of countries
and that's where the contradiction comes
in but we do stand for human rights in
our constitution or Bill of Rights and
in much of our rhetoric and and in some
of the actions and certainly I think in
terms of citizen action in NGOs civil
society we've been very strong on that
score so I think it is a good value to
hang on to and it's something that we
have to do better in implementing hello
I'm curious question about 9/11
I have the impression that American if I
may put it this way American rules of
engagement with the rest of
changed as a result of 9/11 and then I
wonder if you could reflect on what have
been the appropriate responses that's
fine what have been the appropriate
responses by the American government
visa vie responding to 911 in the five
years well I guess the simplest way I
could answer that it's a complicated
question because there's so many
responses and in so many places but
let's look at what happened just two
weeks ago with you with the arrests or
the disruption of this alleged plot to
blow up airliners in London I think what
what this tells us and other less
sensational episodes particularly in
Europe is that is that law enforcement
very well-organized
alert law enforcement you know legal
surveillance developing human contact
you know human intelligence cooperation
between different intelligence agencies
and police and intelligence and so on
can in fact prevent some of the worst
things from happening there been a lot
of arrests in in Europe of what appear
to be some bad guys and if we could
develop the same relationships that we
have among Europeans in to some extent
the United States with countries in the
region where we think much of this is
coming from Pakistan among them but not
exclusively so we would probably do
pretty well in containing the containing
or even reversing the the the global
jihad movement which after all could be
a temporary thing I mean we've seen
other things like this in the past that
Peter out what is the wrong policy for
this is the war in Iraq I mean what we
know of the Madrid bombers a local group
not connected to al-qaeda what we know
of the London train bombers of
year ago a local group not apparently
connected to al-qaeda is that you know
these are angry guys angry for what
reasons hard to say you know lots of
complex accounts on this but what is
clear is that the trigger
for their violence was their anger about
Iraq more than anything else now these
are emblematic of a much larger problem
of the creation of politically violation
of reasons for people in Saudi Arabia in
Iraq in in you know in Jordan in in
Egypt and so on to become to cross a
threshold from being simply angry to
being violent and angry now fortunately
not that many have there are in Iraq but
of course they're fighting a war there
and the question is whether or not they
will then continue as some from the
Afghan cohort did after 1990 if they
will continue as a as a kind of a the
new al Qaeda that is clearly the wrong
way to deal with the war on terror and I
and I find it particularly objectionable
that President Bush yesterday and Vice
President Cheney and others in the
Republican Party and Fox News redundant
to say that of course but are saying
that oh you Democrats don't get it you
don't understand that Iraq is the front
of the war against terrorism no we do
understand that it's in front of the war
against terrorism you created it you
made this happen and that's why you
should not be in power and and it would
be a real shame and a real I think of a
very clear example of of the failure of
our public debate if if that argument
prevails for a long period of time so I
think you know law enforcement you know
it's kind of a mundane answer but it
works
and war not so good
I mean look at Lebanon no you know
what's you think that Hezbollah is
popular in Lebanon yes a lot more
popular than they were in June same
thing microcosm of what's going on in
Iraq and believe me in Israel today
there is a very fervent debate about
this
I mean bitterly you know spirited debate
about this and Israel can do that can
have that debate and we can't that's
amazing was the response in Afghanistan
appropriate at the time well you know I
think given the trauma that 9/11 caused
to the United States it would have been
very hard not to do something in
Afghanistan and what the options are you
know this is one of the problems we have
is critics is we don't really know what
the options are we don't know what the
intelligence tells us we don't know what
you know who's where who's doing what
and so on because it just it rarely
comes to light and certainly not in a
timely way were there alternatives I
just it's just a very difficult question
to answer you recall that when they set
out to in in in October of 2001
in Afghanistan the the the reason for
going in was not to overthrow the
Taliban that that was an afterthought or
at least publicly it was an afterthought
and it came when they were having
difficulty achieving their strategic
objectives so that was a very improvised
operation which of course has only
partially succeeded and I think the
Afghanistan situation we won't know for
a few years really what the results are
thank you for a very interesting book i
justö wonder do we have in the United
States an itch to go around and save all
damsels in distress and then itch to
intervene and set things aright for
example a few years back the Library of
Congress prepared a report for Congress
which outlined our military
interventions abroad from the beginning
of our history 236 now if we count Iraq
and Afghanistan that would be 238 in
addition of those 46 of them have been
in Central America so I just wonder this
is B from our history the first one was
of course in the shores of Tripoli
punishing the Barbary pirates after we
left they resumed their piracy only
Napoleon end of that for example in 53 8
the question is do we have an itch are
we sort of cursed by an itch to set
things aright all over the world at all
times from the very beginning of our
independence in 1853 we enforced Japan
to open in 1898 we forced we took over
the Philippines which were halfway
around the world yes by the way I'm a
retired military I was in the Army from
1942 to 1970 I just wonder is what
drives us to always say these 238 times
to intervene militarily well I think
most of them are it's a good question
and it's not an easy one to answer I
think that there are you know there's
there's a very sort of limited answer in
the sense of it not being very grandiose
and that is we we've intervened a lot to
protect what we consider to be our
interests economic interests
national security interests and and so
on very often misguided but nevertheless
there were those rationales but there
does seem to be more broadly speaking to
your question the the idea of American
exceptionalism that we have we do have a
mission you know there is a there's a
lot of Christian sort of metaphor or
imagery that goes along with discussing
America's role in the world by many
people sort of unconsciously you know
there are many liberals who are still
you know in favor of you know the good
hegemon you know that we're we're strong
we're powerful we should use our
military might to do good in fact many
of the liberal Hawks I write about this
in the book Michael Ignatieff
Christopher Hitchens etc Fred Hiatt
who's still remarkably as the editor of
the editorial page of the Washington
Post yeah you know they promoted this
notion that yes we're gonna go protect
human rights we're gonna get rid of this
monster and so on without coming to
terms I think as many of us did
beforehand that once you start a war you
don't know what's going to happen and
unintended consequences and sue so you
know it's not just a you know a
Shibboleth of the right it's not not
just about interest there is something
about you know sort of internationalism
of you know were the chosen people to do
these things
and it's not it's a hard myth to to get
rid of it's very self gratifying to
think that that's the country we live in
I was wondering when you entered the
human rights question you weren't
mentioned in Guantanamo and I'm from
Austria and I remember European a huge
discussion about this because it
happened on American territory and so I
was wondering because um so we don't
have the last impressions not positive
that's that's why it was really and I
don't know
so well you know the Guantanamo I think
is outrageous to think that a bunch of
fighters you pick up in Afghanistan in a
war you know we invaded after all maybe
for good reasons but we invaded and we
pick up a bunch of fighters and take
them off to this island under no real
legal jurisdiction and hold them for all
these years thinking that's and you know
the excuses they're terrorists they're
going to give us information etc I mean
how valuable can the information they
give us now be just from a practical
standpoint quite apart from the moral or
legal questions associated with this I
mean it's just it's ridiculous and it
came to mind again during the the debate
that started with this London bombing
plot there was the one of the first
right-wing responses on on Hannity and
Colmes I think was I watched these
programs I have two it's like a sore
tooth you know you can't keep your
tongue off of it but you always want to
know what karl rove is thinking every
morning and that that's where you find
out one of the first things they said
was oh you know the british have all
these laws or lack of laws that allow
them to do all kinds of things that we
can't do like detain detaining a suspect
for 28 days well we've been detaining
people in Guantanamo for three years
five years what am I saying five years
we've had we you know we picked up
thousands of American Muslims or Muslims
living in America some some of them
citizens some of them not
and they many of them were detained
hundreds were detained I think they're
still detainees without charging you
know and that is just a fundamental
violation of Human Rights there is no
question about it so you know one of the
imperfections what can I say
it's a bad one but at least there's some
discourse I mean there is some
discussion about it which is good last
question to keep the focus here on
terrorism for a second and and basically
my my concern is why in the world aren't
Democrats media disaffected Republicans
whatever going after bush in terms of
his strong suit namely terrorism simply
saying mr. president you talked about
cut and run 9/11 are words out of your
mouth every five minutes you are the one
who cut and run with respect to Osama
bin Laden still uncaught with respect to
al Qaeda with respect to the Taliban for
the first three months he pursued them
properly and then he completely forgot
about it
they only reappear conveniently in
osama's videotape usually just before an
election to hype the polls and so on and
my concern is this 9/11 comes out of his
mouth every five minutes words put in by
karl rove every single speech by bush
cheney in the very same sentence
combines the words terrorism afghanistan
and iraq one has nothing whatsoever to
do with another with the other he
completely cut and run turn tail ran
away from 9/11 diverted all the
resources to iraq yeah right now as we
speak by better than a ten to one ratio
the budget and the work force power is
in Iraq over Afghanistan he uses
Afghanistan he's naive to the fact that
Taliban's all over the world and why
aren't these people promoting that and
you know attacking him in terms of his
strong suit and you know all this
hypocrisy about becoming hysterical over
9/11 you're living in a pre
Alea world and so I agree I agree
absolutely and I can't understand at
this point why the Democrats are not
more unified on this I think that the
it's partly because some of the
solutions the Democrats have floated
over the years in in during elections
and so on have not seemed to succeed for
example John Kerry talking about law
enforcement as being the leading edge of
our anti-terror campaign and he was
ridiculed for it in in the Oh for
presidential election again the London
situation seems to verify what he was
talking about but law enforcement is
kind of a you know it's it's not a sexy
way of talking about it and I think
there's also a certain amount of
disagreement within the Democratic Party
but as I said earlier and I agree with
you absolutely on this that the that the
actions of Bush particularly with
respect to Afghanistan and even more so
in Iraq and I think now with their I
think puzzling and indefensible
non-action with respect to Israel and
Lebanon in the first weeks of the war
have just created many many more people
who are prone to to vile an action that
thousands but it doesn't take thousands
it just takes a few anyway thank you
again I'll be signing books if you want
Jon chairman on his book 100 ways
America is screwing up the world he's
executive director of MIT Center for